so look Robert spent the last few years
thinking about how weird human behavior
is and how inadequate most of our
language trying to explain it is and
it's very exciting to hear him
explaining the thinking behind it in
public to the first time over to you now
Robert Sapolsky thank you
Phantasy always run something like this
I've overpowered his elite guard burst
into a secret bunker with my machine gun
ready he lunges for his Luger I knock it
out of his hand he lunges for his
cyanide pill I knock that out of his
hand he snarls come to me with
otherworldly strength we grapple we
fight I managed to pin him down and put
on handcuffs Adolf Hitler I say I arrest
you for crimes against humanity here's
where the Medal of Honor version of the
fantasy ends and the industry darkens
what would I do if I had Hitler it was
not hard to imagine once I allow myself
sever his spine at the neck take out his
eyes with a blunt instrument puncture
his eardrums cut out his tongue leave
him alive on a respirator tube fed not
able to speak or move or see or hear
just to feel and then inject him with
something cancerous that's going to
fester and postulate until every cell in
his body is screaming in agony until
every second feels like an eternity in
hell that's what I would do to Hitler
I've had this fantasy since I was a kid
still do sometimes and when I do my
heart speeds up all these plans for the
most evil wicked soul in history but
there's a problem
which is I don't actually believe in
souls or evil and I think wicked belongs
in a musical but there's some people I
would like to
he killed but I'm against the death
penalty but I like schlocky violent
movies but I'm for strict gun control
but then there was a time I was at a
laser tag place I had such a good time
hiding in a corner shooting at people in
other words I'm your basic confused
human when it comes to violence now it's
a species we obviously have problems
with violence we use shower heads to
deliver poison gas letters with anthrax
airplanes as weapons mass rape is a
military strategy we're miserably
violent species but there's a
complication which is we don't hate
violence we hate the wrong kind and when
it's the right kind we cheer it on we
hand out medals we vote for we mate with
our champions of it when it's the right
kind of violence we love it and there's
another complication which is in
addition to us being as miserably
violent species
we're also this extraordinarily
altruistic compassionate one so how do
you make sense of the biology of our
best behaviors our worst ones and all of
those ambiguously in between now for
starters what's totally boring is
understanding the motoric aspects of the
behavior your brain tells your spine
tells your muscles to do something or
other and hooray you've behaved what's
hard is understanding the meaning of the
behavior because in some settings
pulling a trigger is an appalling act in
others it's heroically self sacrificial
in some settings putting your hand on
someone else's is deeply compassionate
and others it's a deep betrayal the
challenge is to understand the biology
of the context of our behaviors and
that's real tough one thing that's clear
though is you're not going to get
anywhere if you think there's going to
be the brain region or the hormone or
the gene where the childhood experience
or the evolutionary mechanism that
explains everything instead every bit of
behavior has multiple levels of
causality let's look at an example you
have a gun
there's a crisis going on rioting
violence people running around
Ranger is running at you in an agitated
state you can't quite tell if the
expression is frightened threatening
angry holding something that kind of
looks like a handgun you're not sure the
stranger comes running at you and you
pull the trigger and it turns out that
thing in this person's hand was a cell
phone so we asked this biological
question what was going on that caused
this behavior what caused this behavior
and this is a multitude of questions we
start what was going on in your brain
one second before you pulled that
trigger and this brings us into the
realm of a brain region called the
amygdala the amygdala which is central
to violence central to fear initiates
volleys of cascades that produce pulling
of a trigger what was the level of
activity in your amygdala one second
before but to understand that we have to
step back a little bit what was going on
in the environment seconds to minutes
before that impacted the amygdala now
obviously the sights the sounds of the
rioting that was pertinent but in
addition you're more likely to mistake a
cell phone for a handgun if that
stranger was male and large and of a
different race furthermore if you're in
pain if you're hungry if you're
exhausted your frontal cortex is not
going to work as well part of the brain
whose job it is to get to the amygdala
and time saying are you really sure
that's a gun there but we need to step
further back now we have to look at ours
two days before and with this we have
entered the realm of hormones for
example testosterone where regardless of
your sex if you have elevated
testosterone levels in your blood you
are more likely to think a face with a
neutral expression is instead looking
threatening elevated testosterone levels
elevated levels of stress hormones and
your amygdala is going to be more active
and your frontal cortex will be more
sluggish pushing back further weeks to
months before where's the relevance
there this is the realm of neural
plasticity the fact that your brain
could change in response to experience
and if your previous months have been
filled with stress and trauma your
amygdala will have enlarged the neurons
will have become more excitable your
frontal cortex would have atrophied all
relevant to what happens in that one
second but we push back even more back
years back for example to your
adolescence now the central fact of the
adolescent brain is all of it is going
full blast except the frontal cortex
which is still half-baked it doesn't
fully mature until you're around 25 and
thus adolescence and early adulthood are
the years where environment and
experience sculpt your frontal cortex
into the version you're going to have as
an adult in that critical moment but
pushing back even further even further
back to childhood and fetal life in all
the different versions that that could
come in now obviously that's the time
that your brain is being constructed and
that's important but in addition
experience during those times produce
what are called epigenetic changes
permanent in some cases permanently
activating certain genes turning off
others and as an example of this if as a
fetus you were exposed to a lot of
stress hormones through your mother
epigenetics is going to produce your
amygdala in adulthood as a more
excitable form and you're going to have
elevated stress hormone levels but
pushing even further back back to when
you were just a fetus back to when all
you were a collection of genes now genes
are really important to all of this but
critically genes don't determine
anything because genes work differently
in different environments key example
here there's a variant of a gene called
Mao alpha and if you have that variant
you are far more likely to commit
antisocial violence if and only if you
are abused as a child genes and
environment interact and what's
happening in that one second before you
pull that trigger reflects your lifetime
of those gene environment interactions
now remarkably enough we've got to push
even further back now back centuries
what were your ancestors up to
and if for example they were nomadic
pastoralists they were pastoralists
people living the deserts or grasslands
with their herds of camels cows goats
odds are they would have invented what's
called a culture of honor filled with
warrior classes retributive violence
clan vendetta's and amazingly centuries
later that would still be influencing
the values with which you were raised
but we've got to push even further back
back millions of years because if we're
talking about genes implicitly we're now
talking about the evolution of genes and
what you see is for example patterns
across different primate species some of
them have evolved for extremely low
levels of aggression others have evolved
in the opposite direction and floating
there in between by every measure our
humans once again this confused barely
defined species that has all these
potentials to go one way or the other so
what does this gotten us to basically
what we're seeing here is if you want to
understand a behavior whether it's an
appalling one a wondrous one or
confusedly in between if you want to
understand that you've got to take into
account what happened a second before
two million years before everything in
between so what can we conclude at this
point officially it's complicated wow
that's really helpful it's complicated
and you better be real careful real
cautious before you conclude you know
what causes a behavior especially if
it's a behavior you're judging harshly
now to me the single most important
point about all of this is one having to
do with change every bit of biology I
have mentioned here can change in
different circumstances for example
ecosystems change thousands of years ago
the Sahara was a lush grassland cultures
change in the 17th century the most
terrifying people in Europe were the
Swedes rampaging all over the place this
is what the Swedish military does now
they haven't had a war in two hundred
years most importantly brains change
neurons grow new processes circuits
disconnect everything in the brain
changes and out of this come
extraordinary examples of human change
first one this is a man named John
Newton the British theologian who played
a central role in the abolition of
slavery from the British Empire in the
early 1800s and amazingly this man spent
decades as a younger man as the captain
of a slave ship and then as an investor
in slavery growing rich from this and
then something changed something changed
in him something that Newton himself
celebrated and the thing that he's most
famous for a hymn that he wrote
Amazing Grace this is a man named Zen
Jia Bay on the morning of December 6
1941 about to lead a squadron of
Japanese bombers to attack Pearl Harbor
and this is the same man 50 years later
to the day hugging a man who survived
the attack on the ground and as an old
man Zhen Jia Bay came to a collection of
Pearl Harbor Survivors at a ceremony
there and in halting English apologized
for what he had done is a young man now
it doesn't always require a decade
sometimes extraordinary change could
happen in just hours consider the World
War one Christmas truce of 1914
powers-that-be had negotiated a brief
truce so that soldiers could go out
collect bodies from no-man's land in
between the trench lines and soon
British and German soldiers were doing
that and then helping each other carry
bodies and then helping each other dig
graves in the frozen ground and then
praying together and then having
Christmas together and exchanging gifts
and by the next day they were playing
soccer together and exchanging addresses
so they could meet after the war that
truce kept going until the officers had
to arrive and said we will shoot you
unless you go back to trying to kill
each other and all it took here was
hours for these men to develop a
completely new category of us
all of us in the trenches here on both
sides dying for no damn reason and who
was of them those faceless powers behind
the lines who were using them as pawns
and sometimes change can occur in
seconds probably the most horrifying
event in the Vietnam War was the Nilay
massacre a brigade of American soldiers
went into an undefended village full of
civilians and killed between 350 and 500
of them mass raped women and children
mutilated bodies it was appalling it was
appalling because it occurred because
the government denied it because the US
government eventually did nothing more
than a slap on the wrist and appalling
because it almost certainly was not a
singular event this man Hugh Thompson
this is the man who stopped the Nilay
massacre he was piloting a helicopter
gunship landed there got out and saw
American soldiers shooting babies
shooting old women figured out what was
going on and he then took his helicopter
and did something that undid his
lifetime of conditioning as to who is in
US and who was of them he landed his
helicopter in between some surviving
villagers and American soldiers and he
trained his machine guns on his fellow
Americans and said if you don't stop the
killing I will mow you down now these
people are no more special than any of
us same neurons same neural chemicals
same biology what we're left with here
is this inevitable cliche those who
don't study history are destined to
repeat it
what we have here is the opposite of it
those who don't study the history of
extraordinary human change those who
don't study the biology of what can
transform us from our worst to our best
behaviors those who don't do this or
destined not to be able to repeat these
incandescent magnificent moments so
thank you
thoughts that really give you a new
mental model about something those are
some of my favorite TED talks and we
just got one Robert thank you so much
for that good luck with the with the
book that was amazing and we're going to
try and get you to come here in person
one year thank you so much thank you
thank you